hello everyone and welcome to part 4 of
agaricus par with most memorable moments
as to be expected part 4 is about game
24 of Kasparov's 1985 match against
Anatoly Karpov this is game 24 and I
guess that's kind of to be expected as
it was after this game that Garry
Kasparov became the world chess champion
now before this match there was actually
a match between Kasparov and Karpov as
most of you probably know in 1984 a year
prior to this match but after playing 48
games the match was still drawn and then
the president of fidei turned down the
match as he said that the match was
deteriorate deteriorating the players
health too much physical and mental and
that the match will be rescheduled for
1985 and then it will restart with a
score of 0 to 0 so this is a game from
their 1985 match and now the match is
limited to 24 games and in game 24
kasparek Kasparov is leading with a
score of 12 to 11 so Karpov has the
white pieces in this game and in order
to retain his title
Karpov must win this game with the white
pieces otherwise Kasparov wins the World
Chess Championship so similar to their
1987 match in game 24 where Karpov was
up a point and Kasparov had to win with
the white pieces now now the situation
is reversed so let's see this game
Karpov opens with E 4 and we have c5 the
Sicilian defense Knight to f3 d6 d4 see
characters Knight captures and Knight to
f6 Knight to c3 and the a6 the knight or
variation with Bishop to e2 and now e 6
transposing into the Scheveningen white
castles as power goes for Bishop to e7
and now f4 Kasparov castles we have King
to h1 getting the King out of this
diagonal so there are no any nasty pins
Queen to c7 and now a4 now in d5 Knight
to c6 Bishop to e3 and rook to e8
we have Bishop to f3 rook to b8
the Queen to d2 and what do you play
here cuz part goes for Bishop to d7 nice
to be three by Karpov and pressuring
that a5 pawn
carpools idea is pushing the pawn to a
five and then playing Bishop to b6 so
Kasparov prevents this he plays b6 and
now Karpov goes for the attack he plays
g4 we have Bishop to c8 now that Karpov
pushed to g4 he kind of weakened the
Kings position here so now as far away
we'll play Bishop back to c8 and maybe
place it to the b7 to kind of counter
this bishop on f3 and maybe maybe harass
the White King in the future
Karpov pushes g5 Knight to d7 and now
Queen to f2 it's it's nicely pressuring
the b6 pawn also ideas like Queen to h4
will be available in the future after a
cup-- of figures out how to make a nice
rook list Bishop to f8 preparing g6
making room for the bishop here and also
kind of kind of releasing this rook but
but not just yet Bush back to g2 we have
Bishop to d7 and rook a to d1 now g6
bishop the see one now Karpov decided to
make a rook lift so he has to get the
bishop on it away from e3 the ideas Ruby
d3 Rock Age 3 and maybe Queen to h4 in
the future threatening the h7 form so
rock beats c8 we have rook to e3 now
nice - before attacking the rook and
rook to h3 Bishop to g7 by Kasparov and
here Bishop to e3 by Karpov and this is
this is the moment Kasparov mentions as
his fourth most memorable moment in over
the board history what to play here with
black he says Karpov traded a very nice
position here with the white pieces
white is better here and it's very hard
for black to actually find the plan let
just has to wade out and see what white
will do as that's kind of the whole
point of the quote about the board you
have to make tough decisions and you
have to resist pressure so you don't
want to make me
anything happen will black here I just
have to resist any idea why has the
white is definitely planning f5 at some
point to break open the position here
and go for the weak weak King here and
also an idea especially for exchanging
the dark square bishop and then bringing
in the Queen to h4 and then going for
the h7 pawn so that's that's the idea
here you definitely don't want to do a
move like Bishop captures on c3 although
this does this does seemingly wound upon
but let's just short
if you play this then Bishop to d4 wins
the gear wins the game immediately you
move the Queen and then rook captures on
h7 rope to h8 checkmate is the threat if
you capture Queen Queen h4 check King g8
and now Queen 288 this is checkmate so
it's a very delicate position and you
definitely have to do something and this
is the move Kasparov says that it was
the hardest move to find over the board
and the move he is talking about is rook
to e7 and if you look at this move it
does look like a weird move you just
placed the rook where it doesn't really
do anything it's probably your least
active active peace now that rook on e7
but it actually does protect the f7 pawn
it allows you to push f6 or f5 to
protect the bishop on g7 and even if the
bishop is exchanged then the rook will
be protecting the h7 points so it does
have a lot of purposes here on e7
another thing is you're still you made a
useful move and you're still letting
white decide what to play and I don't
think Kasparov meant that this was
actually the hardest move to find
because it's it's a hard move to find
rather it's because it's the most
important game of his career if he
doesn't lose this game he becomes the
world champion so that's why you have to
he had to really ride out the pressure
and find a move like rook to e7 and he
said that carpel was walking around the
room and when he came back to the board
and saw this rook to e7 that carpet was
not pleased and he knew that something
something went terribly wrong for him so
here he played the King did you
rook to e8 now the Admiral comes from CH
do it now Kasparov doubles up again a
weird-looking idea as those doubled
rocks aren't really pointing at anything
rook to d1 and here we have f5 now if
each character's on f5 then Kasparov
will release his double rocks G captures
an f6 on Poisson we have Knight captures
and rock the g3 now because Karpov could
have captured on b6 immediately but he
doesn't like the idea of Nigeria play
rook to g3 stopping Knight g4 but here
look to f7 Kasparov again offers the
pawn and here s Karpov doesn't really
see any other way he could gain
advantage he rubs the pawn bishop
captures we have Queen to be 8 and now
Bishop back to e3 now we have night to
h5 attacking the rook rook to g4 and the
knight back to f6 Kasparov is happy with
a draw here rook to h4 we have g5 now
attacking the rook and breaking up this
pawn structure so f captor son g5 and
now comes Knight to g4 attacking the
Queen from the knight and the rook also
the knight is attacking the bishop on e3
Queen to d2 and now Knight captures on
e3 Queen captures on e3 and now Knight
captures on see to grabbing upon also
attacking the Queen on e3 so Queen b6
and here we have Bishop to a8 offering a
trade of Queen's rook captures on d6 and
this was this is the move Karpov has to
make something happen if if he doesn't
go for a point if we place this was also
an option Queen captures queen but after
rook captures and Bishop to h3 offering
the knight on v3 rook captures and now
Bishop captures on e6 attacking both
rooks rook captures on b2 and now Bishop
captures on f7 with check King captures
and now rook captures on h7 it's a it's
a pretty complicated position Karpov
would be up 2 points but Kasparov would
have the bishop prepare for a rook
so it's a pretty equal position but
what a Karpov could go for something as
those pawns can be pushed maybe h4 h5
but probably probably not going to be
able to go for a win here
so after this Bishop to a8 move he
decided not to trade Queens he decided
to play rook captures on d6 rook to be
servin by Kasparov now the Queen has to
move and the knight is unprotected on b3
so Queen captures and now rook captures
and b3 because power grabs a piece we
have rook captures on e6 and now comes
Luke captures on b2
Queen to c4 threatening some discoveries
but after King to h8 there is there is
no move
Karpov can try here it does seem like he
does have a lot of pieces here in the
attack even move like g6 looks very
tempting but after h6 simply locking
down this position there there is
nothing for him to do here rook captures
Queen captures and there is no no plan
here for Karpov anymore he's done a
piece
so after this King to h8 move he saw
that he couldn't really do anything so
he tried the move e5 simply trying to
create something happen hoping for a
blunder from Kasparov but Kasparov seem
to play Queen to a7 this is with Chuck
King to each one if you play King to f1
then simply in 93 this is check this
one's the Queen so he played King to h1
and now comes Bishop captures King
captures and night to d4 a discovered
check from the rook here and in this
position
Karpov resigned game 24 and Kasparov was
proclaimed a world chess champion why
did he resign well there's nothing he
can do here and there are even no more
tricks in the position he's losing the
rook on d6 so let's say King moves
Knight captures and now you could try
maybe something with rook captures on h7
but after a couple of more moves the
King finds a nice safe place on f8 and
and there's no point in doing anything
like this especially not in a World
Chess Championship game a final game as
know everyone in the world playing chess
will see this game so we don't want to
look like you know like like you're just
making some months and smooth so yeah
that was the game after this night 2d
for move I discovered check from the
rook carpet resigned and it was a the
the fourth and probably the most
memorable moment of garriga's peril over
the chessboard Nakata congratulated
Kasparov and his impressive victory over
Anatoly Karpov using his aggressive
style and tall also said that he only
wishes that Kasparov stays on the throne
much longer than touted as tall reigned
for only one year
so yeah that's the game that's the this
little series I had sports most
memorable moments for videos I do hope
you checked out the video number three
as well although I made that video like
four months ago but still still do check
it out it's a very nice 19 move game
between Garry Kasparov and IBM's deep
blue so yeah I would like to thank you
yeah [ __ ] sink and Peter Ashe after all
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot to really appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here they will both be from this
series thank you for watching and I will
see you soon
probably returning to some good old
classics
[Music]